they begin by handing you this
particular quadratic can you read it for
me because I actually can't see with a
reflection it's x squared x squared
minus 4x plus 2 equals 0
thank you so here is an equation it's a
quadratic just like before now notice
this right
they say if alpha and beta are the
solutions to this if alpha beta now I
could work out with the quadratic
formula what alpha and beta are equal to
but the whole point of these guys here
is that I do not need to I don't need to
work out what they are to do any of
these results I just need to identify
what's a what's B what's C so let's do
it
what's a you can get it right from here
careful a it's just the number in front
of x squared which is 1 okay how that be
it's minus 4 this is really important
it's easy to forget that that sign is
there but the sign makes a big
difference so I'm gonna write that down
B is negative 4 and then lastly C is 2
very good this is all I need let's have
a go at actually doing what it is
they've asked I think the first one is
alpha plus beta isn't it ok now I'm
gonna use these results that I've proved
two ways right
I don't have to work out what our from
beta are if I want to know what happens
when I add them I could just go straight
here okay so I'm gonna write minus B
over a I'm gonna encourage you as we
always do when you're learning new
formula write down the formula itself to
get it into your brain and then I'm
gonna look at what B is
and what a is do a substitution - what's
B what do we say it was it's negative 4
so yep I've got two negatives there
which I will cancel in a second bless
you and then I'm dividing through by a
which in this case is conveniently one
that's nice
so I just get an answer for BAM done no
quadratic formula no factorization I
just went straight there okay that was
the first one I'm pretty sure the second
one is just asking for the product right
alpha times beta okay
just like before cuz this is new I'm
gonna write down the formula which is
equal to C over a just to get
my brain and I know what C is I don't
know what a is so I'm going to do the
substitution it's gonna be 2 over 1 I
know that you know what to everyone is
equal to but I encourage you as always
do the substitution step in and skip it
because then it shows you know what
you're doing
and then lastly I just evaluate that
again no factorization no quadratic
formula I just went straight there okay
where's that's to get a little more
interesting is when you look at it
something like C I'm just gonna put an
extra column here what's C asking for
they have a look at it right it looks
like this weird complicated messy thing
you're like what alpha squared beta plus
is it alpha beta squared alpha beta
squared you're like Oh gross what I'm
supposed to work that out no here's the
thing write everything you can see on
the other part we're going to unpack
them write everything you can see it's
like Lego and you only ever need these
two pieces you can construct everything
else just from these basic building
blocks right how could I write this in
terms of what I already know can anyone
tell me it's something I could do to
make that a little easier to write what
can I do with this
alpha and the other one I'm going to
factorize exactly right that's the key
thing right we call this Greek letter
alpha we call this Greek letter when you
put a tail on the B it's a beta okay or
beta you know better beta anyway I'm
gonna factorize out both of them
so let's go I write that out the front
here come my brackets what's left in the
first case alpha and then what's left in
the second case beta and I know what
both of those I've already calculated
them right so I'm gonna write them just
like I saw before that's two and that's
for you care that does that make sense
that's it
now have a look you got a few other ones
here I'm gonna let you have a go at d E
and F without me holding your hand
remember the key is these two building
blocks here right you can use them to
construct everything okay so go old lego
movie master builder on it see what you
can come up with and if you want some
confirmation oh you're kidding against
the your head against the wall let us
know and we'll see if we can help you
out we don't have much time so let's use
it well here's Part D and hopefully the
astute among you have noticed
but just like with C and your instinct
was I know algebra I can factorize this
which helped us out your instinct when
dealing with two fractions that have
different denominators is you should get
a common denominator right that's the
only way you really have to deal with
these fractions of different derives
what would be the common denominator for
two fractions like this alpha beta right
watch I'm going to turn this guy into
something with a denominator of alpha
beta it would be bina on alpha beta
right I've just multiplied the top and
bottom by beta what about the next one
alpha and alpha be a very good once
you've got this you're pretty much there
aren't you because you can combine these
two fractions now that they are on a
common denominator alpha plus beta on
the top alpha beta on the bottom and off
you go
you know what alpha plus beta is do you
know what alpha tie feeder is and then
you've got some answers okay now just
lastly before oh yeah did you ask a
question that's right
a of a minus B well oh I see what you
mean ah no because that would be that
would be this which is not this do you
agree
they're different things okay all right
your 11:00 stay with me Shh this next
one right actually sorry I'm gonna skip
over a because I think you can work it
out without my help
f is a little bit stickier right when
you have a think about this is what you
got right I'm I got F this is F yep
when you look at this some of you might
be thinking ah two squares difference of
squares why can't I use difference of
squares in this case because a lot of
difference it's a sum right you got a
plus you can't just say it would be more
convenient to me if I had a minus there
it's not right so here's what I have to
do and I'm gonna write this in a little
bit of a different color underneath so
you can see I'm doing a slightly
different line of reasoning
I've got squares here let's square to
you and I said before these are the only
building blocks you've got and they're
the only building blocks you need so if
I've got squares here and neither of
those have squares in them then it
stands to reason I'm gonna have to
square one of these right in order to
get something that looks vaguely like
this okay now hopefully at least my
trolley note you got two choices right
50-50 chance you realize that this is
going to be more useful to you because
the alpha and B are already separated
what do you get when you just expand
this alpha squared sorry if you get the
number it will be four squared but I'm
actually interested in algebra right
alpha squared plus suit alpha beta plus
B squared now is this thing here what
I've written in orange is this what I
wanted it's not but it's close isn't it
it's close I just have an extra thing
right so if I subtracted it from this
side I would have what I wanted
you can't just subtract these from one
side of equation you have to subtract
from both sides of the equation so I'm
gonna do this as well okay this guy here
will be these guys are going to cancel
that's the thing that I wanted right and
this you can calculate okay